good day everyone ah and welcome i
i am a
project manager here i have been a
project manager for a while
um
and
my greatest pleasure is interacting with
other people who not only find the value
in project management but find the value
in collaborating and finding new ways
of doing business and opening up
opening up
ways of working together and having fun
while we thrive
yes i have been teaching
project management and helping people
prepare for
the project management professional
certification for over a decade
i've seen changes
in the the profession as well as the
business industry and it's been
fascinating
to watch how both
business
and how we as project managers have
transitioned as the uh as the cultures
and the environments of our companies
have
uh it's it's it's a it's a treat
to be in the front seat of seeing all of
this wonderful stuff happen
one of the things that i will be doing
throughout this whole session is
answering questions
um real quickly
how is a pmp beneficial for engineers or
any professional
i'm going to pull up notepad to
highlight some very important
concepts
and you'll see notepad pop up here real
quickly
uh even before even before i i get into
the material
project management okay
project management is nothing more
than the management of work
that is unique
and time-bound if if some of your work
has never been done before
if some of your work has
is
has a definite starting end
what you'll find with project management
and with the credential
is a very structured and organized way
to
manage and deliver this work
even though it's never been done before
and it integrates
very important concepts
quality
risk
leadership it it um it engages you with
executive management as well as your
project team
it it standardizes a culture and an
approach we're talking about
a very rigorous form and the level of
statistical analysis in estimation
as well as
and a way to
uh
to uh integrate
variance analysis in all aspects
of decision making within the process of
creating something that's never existed
before
so if that's your work
project management and the project
management professional
credential will assist you
now let's get back to the material what
we're really here to talk about
the project management professional
credential the pmp
we will talk about the value
and
both economic and non-economic
components
we'll review the test
and i'm going to be using feedback from
uh
trainees who've gone on to
take the test and get get it easily
within the first try
i
i work with what is it let's see here
easily between 75 and 125 people a month
and i keep in touch with many of them
and i
enjoy the feedback from the
people who take the test
that's what you're experiencing today
the ones who have
actually
taken the test within the last three to
four weeks
um the test requirements what does it
take to sit for this test
um and again i'll be providing you
feedback from the people who have taken
the test i do have some feedback from
trainers
and what they have found their attendees
i've been doing this like i said since
2004 i've been preparing people for the
test i have not seen
a deviation
in what i'm presenting today for the
most part except for the salaries
and
one thing i want you to
think about throughout the whole thing
as we progress
both companies and project managers are
asking us
um trainers as well as the project
management institute
how can we get people
who have more leadership
who are able to help
with business decision making who have
the ability to take this skill with
something that's never been done before
and extract the value to move their
business
forward quickly
project management is uh is positioned
to be that skill set
okay the test itself
tests both
your education and experience
you have requirements in uh in
um
[Music]
studying project management you also
have uh requirements with experience
we'll go over that in a couple minutes
the test however also
tests what i call competence there are
many situational questions that
the
the test
um
puts you in and you're posed questions
with very ambiguous
information just like a real world
environment
and you're asked to solve a problem
now
on top of that
if the the other requirements are very
rigorous
you are required to take an oath
to uh to uphold a level of ethics and
professional conduct that's a little
above
what a normal
normal job application and acceptance
require you
also
after
you have your pmp
for as long as you want to have it
you need to continue to grow
continue to study and continue to
collaborate with other project managers
so
it's it's not just a cr
certification that you get this is a
credential that recognizes you
as a professional
the test itself
200 questions four hours
so what does that boil down to
1.2
minutes
per test average question
so all questions are
multiple choice
four possible answers
and so you are in a very uh um you have
a very specific time frame
and it adds a little bit of
tension
however
um
it's it's not unmanageable
it's it's establishing and setting a
regular pace
uh the test is also closed book
you go into a third-party proctored
environment
you have none of your personal effects
with you at the testing station
you're given
a number two pencil with white paper you
have a physical calculator or you have a
calculator on the screen
and that's that's basically what you'll
be working with
it's uh it is you
and the test that's all
now it sounds a little daunting
but
uh again it's it's there is a method to
everything if you understand it
you have a credential
along with your name that's recognized
across the planet
so
the project management institute or pmi
they host
not only
the tests and the questions
they they do a lot of research on behalf
of project management and project
managers
they put out a salary survey they have
one just come out at the end of the year
ninth edition
and that's where i'm getting my monetary
value
they also
do a lot of surveys and research
in order to understand the direction
that companies would like project
management to go and the direction
companies are going with the need for
the skill set of project management
that's where i'm pulling my research my
data
um
first of all let's talk about the
financial value
this is one of the reasons why people
get a pmp
even in the united states it's very well
known
that job applicants
are filtered quickly by whether they
have a pmp or not in order to sit and
take the the pmp test
you need
three to eight years of project
management
experience so having a pme
gives you that recognition you pmi has
done the work of the company and
validated that that person has
experience
that means the median salaries are
pretty nice
and
over a year year over year a person with
a pmp can expect to have about a 5
salary increase and this is this is from
pmi doing this type of survey
um many many years in a row
now that's the median salary right if
you look at the upper 25
of the salary
of the professionals these are the
people handling the major projects as
well as
decision makers with the project
management skill set
they're running
this is global this is not tied to any
nation
if you do go to pmi.org
you can find this data and you can
actually
look up your nation and find what what
the uh
what the value is
um also
now that's project management with a pmp
you can expect to be
um to be one of the 47 percent above
this median and this is a global salary
um expectation this is not u.s i have
some u.s members in the back of my
presentation
but like i said you can look up the
nations um the various nations that you
belong to for
the survey results
over
now
there's also a differentiator
as you stay within the profession and
grow
that gives another
bump to that salary
five years is huge
almost all nations um
the the pmp with um
[Music]
two to five years
in that position
will give you
an incredible salary increase
it's almost double in some nations i was
looking at the data and i was going this
can't be right
yes it is
yes it is jim
so
non-monetary value is there as well
the pulse of the profession the survey
asked
major corporations
some questions and these were
corporations who
have
um constantly
stated that project management is one of
their core capabilities and is the
reason they're so competitive
now that's that's a big statement
that's saying that we hold this skill
set in high value
and they are some of the most successful
and yet
they say only 67 about two-thirds of
their projects are truly successful
first of all
think about that two-thirds these are
people who say we cannot we cannot keep
our doors open without projects and
project management
and
they're only getting two-thirds of their
projects right
to me that says there's a lot of room
for more project managers here
and the discipline and skill that
project management brings
on top of that
there are other
non-monetary values first of all
they understand project management
a lot of companies
if if you are a student
will tell you in one way or another
that they don't really understand
project management and how to extract
the value
but there are companies out there that
do
these companies who quote unquote get
project management
they are
significantly more likely to invest in
their employees that means training
that means time to do things right
that means
giving
project managers competitive salary and
authority and power to do what they or
project managers know
is the right way to get work done
and also
these companies understand
standardized process so
project management and
and the
the project management life cycle
the the pmp tests you
on something called plan driven where
the scope
the budget
and the schedule
are planned out at in as early as
possible
and this means the requirements
around that are explored analyzed and
and exposed
in a very methodical
very
calculated way
when you are investing 130 to 500
million dollars in a project
you
you entrust that
to the professionals and the employees
who respect that the most and this is
the project manager
now on top of all this okay
this is this is the key thing that i
keep on seeing and i've been watching
this over the last three years we we
were all seeing
companies who are cutting back
and not investing
in in their infrastructure or not
investing in their people they were
trying to
actually
make as much revenue and profit as
possible however
in the area of project management it
seems to be a little bit different
they're asking more and they're willing
to invest more in these type of people
these are surveys these are the
companies who are investing so project
management it it it's evident why i'm
seeing not just
six to 12 people in my classes every
month
but i'm seeing 20 to 40 to 50 people in
the classes
and that's not enough project managers
guys
this is this the companies every year
are saying the same thing and seeing
these very successful very dedicated
very exciting
excited professionals getting into this
and companies keep on going back to
project management institute and say if
we need more you guys are doing a great
job we need even more
that's a big message for all of us
the test
tests you on a set of skills for
managing and directing work
that's never been done before
and that has a very specific start and
end
now how do you do that
and and what is the test what what are
the experience of the people taking that
that's what you came to hear about today
first of all preparing for the test
there's a lot of memorization
there's a lot if you don't memorize well
there's a lot of literature out there
and there's a lot of trainers like
myself
and um
companies like simply learn
who
collect best of breed
and they they find out what works the
best how do you manage
how do you manage all this information
how you prioritize information
there's also sources of material that
give you guidance
the project management body of knowledge
is only one piece
there are other piece that trainers will
provide you
and you know what the biggest piece is
the biggest piece
is people collaborating
talking about this amongst
professionals
the ability right now
for
students
and people who are just studying project
management
to ask people like me is huge
forums
where we get together and we actually
share information on a regular basis are
becoming very prevalent in fact
companies like simply learn are
generating their own community
communities of experts
and that's why
we have the ability to
and we have the opportunity to speak to
people like you
the project management body of knowledge
is the
blueprint for doing projects
it's a it's aligned with the iso
project management standard
and it follows a very rigorous
methodology that's been in place for
ah quite a while it's uh prop pmi has
been around since late 1960s
the pmp um certification helpful for
software qa based quality assurance
there's a there's a huge standardized um
quality
knowledge area and it's built around the
work of deming and sure if you guys know
as well as joseph duran
you know
quality is conformance to requirements
and fitness for use
so yes
it applies very directly to that
to that topic
if you're in manufacturing
and you've never done software projects
it's a kick in the past i tell you uh so
you think about companies that write
software like video games
they write software and and i it just it
just
thrills me to think about it they
actually put
software in production when it's 70
percent complete think about blizzard
the people who write world of warcraft
and starcraft and all those right
they actually put their software out in
the public domain
for their
for their people who want to try it out
you know production great software is
only 70 complete could you imagine doing
the same thing with an automobile
or a building
yeah oh yeah and and it's not only that
but the ability to apply
quality management risk management the
assessment
and the variance analysis and all of the
disciplines around were doing things
right
and integrating the components of
of number one
the leadership skill set required to
manage these complicated endeavors
with
connecting the value of your project
back to
the value that the
company can extract immediately
one of the focuses on the test and
if you want to at the end of this we can
start talking about how the test is
changing right now
is the the project manager's focus not
just on delivering something within time
you know it's never been done before but
also
it's connecting that to a distinct
business value and creating a very
transparent
traceability of that you don't just sell
a project
you go back and you validate
that that project is at least or more
value than what you sold with that let
me continue my discussion here okay we
have other we have other
considerations that make the test tricky
many situational questions
you can imagine a test that says you
have two senior engineers
and they come up to you and they say
we need help um we have to share the
same software
and we we
we don't have um we're arguing and we
need to
we need to solve this problem
how do you approach this as a project
manager what's the best way and why is
it the best way
it's these type of situational questions
with very little information that you're
required to figure these type of things
out
okay i'll get back to that question in
just a second
so
you have a blueprint
you have your personal experience
and how do you connect all those
together
this is the job that makes the make this
tricky we all have learned
that different organizations different
cultures you know you can imagine a
software company
and a hardware company a hardware
manufacturing company
they will look at project management in
a different mindset
and the blueprint
the pembach
is the standardization of how you do
projects across all of these different
environments so you can imagine there's
a little bit of work involved
in translating and learning to build
these intellectual conceptual bridges
in order to integrate your experience in
with the standard
frameworks
that makes it a little bit tricky and
it's an investment in time
in doing any transition of projects
what would we need to focus on
and also
technology how do you manage technology
and and is project management a good
technology
uh
management tool as you're as you're
working and i assume you're talking
about integration of technology in with
the business so we look at we look at
things
and you'll you'll learn this as you
prepare for the test as not just tools
they're tools processes and procedures
um we take a very integrated approach
project managers and project management
takes a very integrated approach
and we see
you know that cloud computing
is part of a solution that includes not
just
the technology
but it has business components and it
has the almost more important people
components
so you have to take all of those into
consideration and you have to know
how one impacts the other
if you talk about cloud computing and
bringing cloud computing into
a business process or a business
environment you can imagine
that this if it's not
introduced approached
and managed properly it can cause a lot
of
very violent change in cultures
business and professional cultures if
they're not prepared for this
can be
can experience a lot of
violence i'm not talking about
physically violent
but um very
transformative
violence and and things are going to be
changing and ambiguous for a long time
if not managed
appropriately this is where project
management skill comes in especially for
new and emerging technologies
so what are the unique skills we'll talk
about that and we'll get to that here in
just a second actually
preparing for the test
takes into account those skills
we'll talk about that
that's where we are now
first of all before you take the test
you need to
have some experience in project
management
uh about three and a half years
you know and in the last eight years
you need to have documented
proof of about 4500 hours if you have an
undergraduate or graduate degree
if you have a three or four year degree
from the university
it's 4 500 hours
and that means about three and a half
years
you know a third or more of your time
you will have been doing work
that's unique never been done before
and is time bound but if you look at the
work you're doing
business is changing so fast so i
guarantee you you're already
working and you're leading
activities on projects and that's what's
required to take this test you also need
35 hours of some type of classroom
training
that's why simplylearn is here to
number one
provide documentation of that training
as well as
bring people like myself
um in contact with you
and help you understand the best ways of
passing these tests
what does it take to prepare for from an
individual standpoint
an hour a night
if you ask a trainer to boil it down to
one one sentence
you'll be sitting down for about an hour
nine percent to eight weeks studying
reviewing
and you're reviewing
um
questions
you know basically what happens is
pmi
creates a professional relationship with
companies like simplylearn and they
validate that the material including
practice test questions
are in alignment with the real test
and so the one of the value is that you
have access to this content
and you're reviewing the test questions
and and confirming that you have all
this material cover
you can imagine then you're using both
short term and long term memory short
term memory because there's a lot of
questions that have to do with concepts
and definitions
and then
those situational questions which are
some of the most difficult
that put that experience
alone will
teach you
and that's i get back to my point
connecting with other project managers
connecting with the experienced project
managers like myself
especially like what you're doing asking
questions is the best one of the best
ways to support your preparation for
these tests
now the other thing is
the test also
looks at
um your ability
to understand what the standards and exp
and your experience
provide you you have an analytical
mindset
that's required as project manager one
of the nice things is if you don't have
if you have questions
you have the ability to go out and get
them
we all know
that pmps again take an oath to help you
and so anybody with a pmp
will be
um will
be an open book for questions and
they'll they they will be on their honor
to help you answer them this is the type
of person who makes a good project
manager somebody who's willing to go out
and dig into the details to find that
answer
you will find yourself preparing for the
test you're hitting a very
um a very powerful concept for you and
you struggle with it and you struggle
with it and then the light bulbs go on
you'll be doing this throughout your
test preparation this is the type of
mindset that's required not giving up
its determination
to actually follow through on the
technical
as well as the non-technical questions
you have about the skills
and the
knowledge of project management
unique skills that make us different
from other other types of managers
uh
the the foundation
of project management within the uh
within the project management body of
knowledge
is a rigorous approach
to
[Music]
studying analyzing
and determining the best solution or the
best option
it also provides
a very strong and disciplined approach
to change and change management
successfully passing the first time the
test is not difficult
it's not difficult it's tricky
if you prepare
and if you if you uh methodically study
and you have a plan
it's a lot easier
if you have short-term retention
you know if you're able to memorize
and there are
ways to learn how to memorize better
it's a lot easier to take the test
also if you have a real reason
to
attain the
pmp now if you have a business need you
know the business of you as an
individual if you run this as
if you run this preparation as a
business
then you'll do this right you'll prepare
and you'll be able to get your pmp
well within six weeks
those i found those type of
students
who have a real need to to
either transition out of their position
or make themselves more marketable
yeah it's these these are the things
this is all common sense if you just sit
down and think about this
it's it's all common sense
test takers and this is in the last
three or four weeks this is the feedback
i've gotten
no shortcuts
you do the work
there are no
there's no
single silver bullet that a trainer can
provide you in fact all of us come to
this test
from a different background a different
set of knowledge so
each one of us have to explore and
determine our unique silver bullets for
ourselves
and again the test isn't trick isn't
hard it's tricky
so
you're under a
time crunch
and you have to carefully analyze both
the question and answer and then you
have to apply your knowledge and skills
so it's a it's an environmental
trickiness
as well as
as
knowledge and experience trickiness
one of the other things that these test
takers have said is
as soon as you start
uh
preparing for the test
schedule it
make it real
we're coming back to that need drives
success
this is the key make it real
and you'll actually drive your personal
commitment
to
[Music]
the investment you know in time
having a plan
you know again making it real and
following that we're very good as
project managers establishing a plan and
the structure that supports
following through and extracting value
from the results of that plan
use these skills as you're preparing for
the test
that's what they all say coming out of
it
and there are a lot of pieces
there
there are 47 processes
that you're learning and how they fit
together and and understanding how the
big concepts across projects work
how does change work
what do i have to consider
when i'm when i as a project management
manager and faced with a change to my
project how do i manage change
without letting something fall through
the cracks
so what i recommend
go out to the forums find out what
people are saying who have recently
taken the
test find out what people in your
project management community you work
with a pmp
i i know all of you do
ask them the direct questions how has a
pmp changed their work how did taking
the pmp
change
how they approach project management
they'll they'll say general things like
they expose me to new skills like
precedence diagramming and scheduling
earned value analysis let's see here
change quality risk management
communications management
procurement you know purchasing it
helped me understand how purchasing
um works within a project and contracts
all of these it's not just the
accumulation
but how they fit together to deliver
something that's never been done before
research this ask people these questions
start initiation activities initiation
is a group
of processes that establish
how
feasible it is
to do the project itself is this
something that's good for you right this
moment
it it's the and that's the big question
it's not is this good for you
you can extract value from the project
management skills right now and it'd be
great it helps you in everything your
personal life as well as your
professional life however
is it right for you right now and that's
what these initiation activities will
help you with
understand how you as an individual
learn
um like i said
um there's a lot of memorization
so you should understand are you a good
memorizer or do you need other
strategies to help you
more consciously apply memorization
find your reason
to pass the test not just take it but
pass it
also talk with us
anybody with a pmp
should be able to help you walk through
these these questions is it good for me
to take this test now
is it good for me to uh is is this right
for me with my
with my
career goals and the direction i'm
taking my profession my professional
work
make a plan
base your schedule and cost
on your training needs evaluate this is
how much it's going to cost me
what am i going to get out of this build
your business case
and if you establish that it makes it
more real
include in your planning work-life
balance
you're doing this for a reason
what's the business reason for doing
this and articulate it very crisply this
will allow me
to have more control
and more
and more direction
in my career
you know things like that make these
value statements for yourself
and also in your plan don't don't
forget
to add celebration in there and and
this is
i i sort of chuckled when i went through
my uh my workshop back in 2003
when the when the trainer said that but
it makes so much sense looking backwards
and seeing the other people who did this
this is this is an endeavor
and you're marking a transition point in
your career when you step up to take a
test this is a big thing
celebrate
the more realistic you make your plan
the greater chance you'll succeed
this is all common sense if you sit down
and think about it and that's what
project management is you apply common
sense
reliable process trumps wishing and
holding every time
this is a guarantee this is this has a
broad and a very uh
colored history project management
and the pmp
and it always leads back to the same
thing
it's not hard
there's just a lot of detail
and by carefully waiting through the
detail and measuring and analyzing and
following proper decision making
you'll have guaranteed success
that's all it is
there is a lot this these numbers come
from uh
the the
last half of last year
and you can see on the left graphic
that
although
salaries across the united states
may vary
they all trend in the same direction
this is very important
you can expect no matter where you are
no matter which industry
no matter which nation and i showed you
that
you can expect the pmp
will give you an opportunity for for
movement inside or outside your company
but also it continues
you know as you as you hold as you
retain your pmp it will continue to add
value
there's also
not just project management
project management is one
of the professions around projects that
that companies are learning about what
about project directors what about
project management offices
what are these things and how do you
manage those within a company and how
does
a company find them among leaders who
are able to integrate these tools and
skills
into the business
those jobs
you can imagine are growing
and those positions are continue to be
defined
and the roles more understood as we
progress
and those salaries
at that leadership level the executive
level are also
heightened
by
people with pmps
that is cool
um let's see here
here's contact information you can
always go to
www.simplylearn.com as well
but
again
as a training provider simply learn
touches a lot of people's lives
it works directly with companies as well
as the public like what we're doing
today
over 2 000 certified and experienced
trainers like myself if you go on to the
public forums with simply learn
you have access to
that that training community across the
planet i'm just one of many guys
and i'm one
of many disciplines what about agile
what about
uh lean and six sigma
what about it information library what
about prince and prince2 by the way i'll
answer that question in just a couple
minutes
there is
a very
structured in a very well understood way
we support
the pmp credential
and i can talk about that as well
understanding applying practicing and
assessing built on what the demonstrate
cycle
plan do check act
um qa guys uh
let's see here's pmp certification
helpful yes yes again the integrated
component it brings leadership skill
the business acumen you know the the
ability to take the project work
um and confirm and being able to extract
business value
as well as
make sure something's delivered on time
within within budget
according to the the
project management life cycle
transition
projects transitional projects again
highly integrated
and it's all about the people
when you're making change within a
business and you you always
reflect the change not just with
technology not just with processing
procedure but people with the major
integration projects that i've handled
it's always evidence you spend a year
and a half two years working with the
culture of a company and organization in
order to do this right um let's see here
what are the unique skills
that make us different pmp unique skills
again there's a stress
there's a huge stress
on assessment
on analysis
plan do check act
we actually understand
we ask questions um
when you're studying the material
there's a big
focus
on asking why
and also
focus on
once you understand hey
we can apply this change to the project
it's not going to impact the schedule
and as a pmp you learn okay
not the schedule how about cost
how about scope how about risk have a
quality
how about all of the stakeholder
requirements and how do i tie all this
together
how do i take an integrative approach to
understand how change will impact
and more and more project managers are
asked
to include in the stakeholders executive
management
you know the people who are establishing
the vision
that these projects support
what's the difference between pmp and
prince2 they don't both follow the same
iso standard 21-500 okay
now
at that point
they take a little bit of a different
approach
prince2
has very
variations
in levels you can actually get an
entry-level prints too which gives you
an understanding about the
project framework
not not directly leading and directing
activities but participating in projects
there's another
credential
that pmi has that covers this capm which
which again is entry level
which proves that you have experience
working on projects
and you passed a less rigorous test
however
uh prince2 has four levels and they they
actually test and evaluate the the it's
not quite so situational
as the pmp is
those are the major differences
what's the pdu
after gaining pd is what's its validity
well first of all
um you have you have to show a certain
amount of education
in project management in order to sit
for the test after you've sat and you
succeeded in the testing you need to
continue
your professional development
and that's what we call
that's where the pdus come into play
professional development units and these
are generally an hour
of your time invested is one pdu
there are a lot of local
project management institute chapters
there i'm i'm certain there's one around
you and they provide access to these
pdus
very economically some of them are free
and you're able to uh participate in
these and so you can actually attain
these very easily
by
developing and
and demonstrating your expertise
like what i'm doing today i'm earning a
professional development unit i had to
do the research i have to present
and this actually qualifies as one of
those type of events for me to gain it
and yes there's incredible value in it
it forces you to continue to grow
and
as pmi changes
their test
and the education requirement
you have
inside knowledge on the direction the
profession is being taken with all these
corporations they're asking us
more leadership
more business
understanding so you can imagine in the
next two to five years
you're going to see in the public domain
a lot of focus
on education
and
leadership as well as
business management
not much project management experience
to what extent does a pmp give me an
edge for a more secure job first of all
it gives you more access to job
opportunities
if it's very easy
for companies to take a list of
prospective employees and filter out all
the non-pmps
this is well known this has been going
on for the last decade that's the first
thing you need to consider
the second thing is
it provides you a standard
in leadership and management we're not
talking about managing 5 or 10 or 50
people
it's talking about
skill sets and knowledge and experience
that manages the people
who manage these these teams we're
talking not just
about entry level management here okay
that's the pmp guys
and also its leadership understanding
how you integrate
your visionary executive management
participation in with the people who are
doing the work you're sitting in the
middle of this mix of the people who
have established the vision and the
direction the why
the people who have created the why of
your projects
with
your project team who creates the how
and as a project manager you're
balancing both of those i know we're
going over a little bit of the time and
i'll i'll be here
as long as i have questions going on do
you need to renew your certification
after a certain period yes
every three years
and
you renew
by keeping track of these professional
development units you need 60
every three year cycle it costs
us dollars it costs 60 dollars to retain
your credential every three years but
yeah you you basically
have documented proof of continued
education training and participation in
project management there's more details
up on the website around the credential
on that
what is a
prerequisite for the certification exam
let me put it up on the screen again
here you go left hand side
three day
years leading and directing project
tasks
you know about 4 500 hours that means
about a third to a half of your work
is work bleeding and directing
activities around
something that's never been done before
the credential
and again this is sort of funny is the
credential only for project managers
most companies i i talked to a lot of my
trainees across 2014
and at that point it may be a little
different now
at that point the companies they
represented it seems like about six to
seven to eight out of ten companies
did not have a job description
or a job ladder for project managers
actually
most people who were getting the pmp
even as recent as
they didn't have project manager as
their title they were looking for
something that tied leadership
business knowledge
and the ability to create something new
within a certain amount of time within a
budget all together and that's what the
pmp
uh represents
so it's not just for project managers
what's a passing grade
my answer is yes the the test itself
does not give you a passing grade
it's a trick
what they do is they evaluate you based
on
your your answers
and they say are you um
in in groups of knowledge
are you uh
i'll think of the word here in a second
i'm sorry
um are do you have a level of capability
and understanding
there's more information on that up on
the website too we can talk about more
of that more
how do you resolve formulas in one
minute
well first of all there's ways to
prepare for the test even as you're
going through the test itself and how do
you keep these formulas in in top of
mind
a lot of its short-term memory uh
the formulas we're talking about how do
you build a business case you know how
do you financially justify a project
that has to do with present uh present
value calculations
it has to to uh it incorporates cost
versus investment in the project those
type of calculations also
if you're looking at
variance to schedule variance to
budget and then if you're forecasting
there's a few formulas around that
with a methodical approach you can
actually integrate this into your
short-term memory however
you're at risk because if you don't
retain that memory if you don't continue
to keep memorizing this stuff within
five days it's like exercise it's gone
so it's it's a commitment
that you're going to make across about
four to six to eight weeks by keeping
this
in your short-term memory
again we all know if you use something
like this every day for six to eight
months it's going to trickle in
from your short-term to your long-term
memory
what's the difference in the new test
that's a great question guys um this
actually um is is i touched on earlier
more focus
on leadership aspects
more focused on
the impact of the project to
the business objective why are we doing
this and the project manager's
participation
about 20 to 24 of the questions are
going to be focused and the answers will
revolve around that
mindset
you know you're not just an entry-level
project manager anymore
you're actually looking at
supporting and participating in
the vision of the project that's what
we're looking at the the other technical
aspects that i've been talking about
project management aren't going away
either
you know nothing's going away what we're
seeing is
these parts are being
being focused on so the test is
reflecting that
is pmp or agile more preferred and the
answer is yes
uh the project management professional
focuses on something called plan driven
where the requirement is the scope of
the work you know the body of the work
and the work and the deliverable
as well as the details
are
as crisp as possible up front that being
said there are some types of work and
there are some situations where you're
going to embrace ambiguity so
the pmp teaches
and
the this project management approach
teaches that agile
as a methodology
is very good in certain areas of project
work where you have a lot of ambiguity
and you have a lot of change
and not just transformative change but
you have a lot of very powerful change
we're talking about we're talking about
companies
that are competitors
collaborating on work
how do you manage these
potentially devastating
and
these these very
delicate
types of projects
that's where that's where this this
level and this focus of project
management applies
yeah and it's not it's not a preference
it's actually understanding these
different types
of project of projects
and understanding which methodology is
the most appropriate and it's not i'm
i'm talking at the high level right
agile versus
um
versus uh plan driven
but it even trickles down to the
individual activities
you you as a project manager are
expected to understand
the details and how to extract the
details out
you know if i put the landscape in
uh the around the restaurant before i
move the heavy equipment in you know is
that going to
force me to do the landscape twice
it's it's the ability to
learn and integrate
you know this this type of thinking into
everything you do it's a very active
approach
you know dealing with people
dealing with technology
dealing with changing the way business
works i started working with data
centers early on
and it was evident
that you have to change
the way people think about data
first and then you can start doing the
project you can imagine everybody having
an external hard drive under their desk
and you're going into a company that's
150 years old
with about 80 000 people like this and
convincing them
that centralizing their data is more
secure
and
it actually gives them a lot more
freedom
that takes time
you know you're changing your changing
cultures and that's the level
of project management we're talking
about here with
people who have pmps you know it's it's
the skill set
um of working with people
and process and business
and it's it's it's like
establishing
you know a home base for humanity on
mars that's the type of projects we're
talking about guys
it's it's not that huge and important
in your day-to-day uh profession
but it's that mindset
and and getting back to what i started
saying
that's the value that companies have
found with projects and project managers
especially those who who
invest in the credential
in actually attaining this foundational
knowledge
we will uh we um
we're here
go over to simply learn
and
spend time with us there
ask 24x7 support go over to
community.simplylearn.com and ask more
questions both about simply learning
project management and the pmp and all
your questions will be uh will be
provided to you it's not tim
it's not tim it's us as a community who
are here to support you
you